he's cool don't use Taylor Swift is sad
and grossed out by music manager Scooter
Braun after he purchased her former
label which includes her master
recordings
[Music]
the 29 year old pop star posted a
lengthy message to tumblr on Sunday
accusing scooter of bullying her for
years and now again with his recent
purchase of her former record label Big
Machine et has reached out to reps for
Taylor and scooter for comment I
wouldn't want to do this if I didn't
have a hundred percent control I
wouldn't want to do this if it was up to
somebody else in Taylor's essay she says
she begged her former label heads Scott
Borchetta for years for a chance to buy
her masters but says she wasn't allowed
to in 2018 Taylor left Big Machine and
signed with Universal Music Group she
said she knew that someday Scott would
eventually sell the label which includes
her masters but what happened next
Taylor says she never expected Scott's
selling the label to scooter in a
reported 300 million dollar deal Taylor
says she found out about the sale of the
label with the rest of the world as it
was announced publicly on Sunday but
according to Scott who shared a long
message on the big machine website on
Sunday he alleges he texted Taylor the
night before the news broke after Taylor
learned of the sale she claimed quote
all I could think about was the
incessant manipulative bullying I've
received at scooters hands for years
Taylor shared two examples both centered
around her past drama with Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West quote Kim
Kardashian orchestrated an illegally
recorded snippet of a phone call to be
leaked and that scooter got his two
clients together to bully me online
about it Taylor posted this screenshot
of a years old post by Justin Bieber
that shows him facetiming with scooter
and Kanye in the caption Justin wrote
Taylor Swift what up the other example
Taylor references Kanye's music video
for his song famous quote scooters
client Kanye West organized a revenge
porn music video which strips my body
naked I feel like me and Taylor might
still have sex why I made that
now several stars are weighing in with
their two cents Justin Bieber apologized
for sharing that Instagram post but went
on to defend scooter insisting scooter
has always loved Taylor
and suggested they handle their drama by
talking in person instead of social
media
Demi Lovato also has scooters back so
does scooters wife Yael Cohen she
slammed Taylor as being a bully herself
writing who are you to talk about
bullying the world has watched you
collect and drop friends like wilted
flowers Yale also stood up for her
husband and added don't blame him
because Kim caught you in a lie over on
Team Taylor palsy cara delevingne
todrick Hall and Selena Gomez's mom
Mandy TV wall shared messages of support
for the pop star on social media
[Music]